[Music]
I had a nice night last night I went out
and had a few uh slippery American
cocktails it's always a good time I
really I just mean I had some
drinks yeah but life is dull so I
thought I'd say slippery American
cocktails trying to add spice to my
which was also why I was drinking you
know but you know what needs to I think
needs to stop happening people need to
stop judging other people based on what
they order at the bar can we all agree
that that needs to stop I am tired of it
it's all this pressure there's too much
pressure to make the right choice I know
what I'd like to drink but you know
what's entirely different what I want
people to see me
drinking you don't want to be the one
guy watching the game drinking Spiced
Rum out of half of a coconut you know
what I mean so yeah go
Bruins hard to navigate amidst the
pineapples
you don't want to be you want to order
the right thing so I usually order
Scotch because I like to pretend I'm a
man specifically Don
Draper but I don't like Scotch no one
does really it tastes like a burnt down
log
cabin but it was probably invented by
some huge Scotsman with a sword and he's
really strong so no one wanted to
disagree with him you know what I mean
just like isn't this
great
totally
I'm just saying no one who ever tried
Scotch for the first time dranking was
like this is what I've been looking
for
yeah but I get it it's social
advertising you know what I mean you're
drinking poison you're drinking
something strong to let the girls see be
like look I'm ingesting
acid and I can still do sex to
you it's a strong drink choice but it's
not what I actually want to drink you
know what what I want to drink white
wine that's right oh I feel you back
away I'm done hiding I want to drink
white wine why it tastes like
daylight it's fruity and smooth and
delicious a baby would drink it a baby
you leave a baby in a room with a bottle
of reasing he's going after it just a
drunk baby like I don't need your tits
no more you know what I mean drunk baby
coming soon to TNT
but guys don't drink it because it sends
the wrong message you drink white wine
you order white wine it looks like you
want to sit outside of a museum and
Paris with full shopping bags and all
your girlfriends just
gabbing and you know what I do what I'm
saying is can we all just relax it's all
the same in the perfect world I think
anyone should feel comfortable drinking
a Cosmopolitan proudly but part of the
problem with the cosmo is the glass wear
you know it's pink it's a triangle just
holding it looks like a bikini box
and the glass is a big problem cuz you
hold it by the stem you look like you
just picked like a glass flower for your
unicorn
bride I'm going to present this to my
love or you can hold it like this like
David Bowie Labyrinth style but that's
not quite right either it just kind of
looks like you're giving dmbe matombo
the turn your head and cough
exam you're going to be okay big
fella either way it's so top heav you're
holding one of those Cosmos you're going
to spill half of it on the way back to
your booth just splashes everywhere like
a hyperactive pudgy kid in the
tub that's my impression of a
Cosmopolitan and a pudgy kid in the tub
I just think we need to relax every
drink is alcohol just wearing a
different costume sometimes it's a
floral dress that's champagne sometimes
it's like an old timey handlebar
mustache that's whiskey and sometimes
it's a Reagan mask with duct
tape oh you've had Jagermeister that's
right
that's an intense beverage I'm just
saying stop judging alcohol is alcohol
I'll be okay with your dark hoppy ale
you be okay with my halfs spilled Cosmo
on the rocks with a white wine Chaser
then I'll meet you out on the dance
floor and we can settle this like
[Applause]
gentlemen